que nous inviter théo lobry animateurs
du comité bernie sanders aux français
mondiale aux présidents de républiques
en sauveur 6 merci messieurs d'être en
direct sur rt france randy aloses alors
on s'attendait à une vague bleue
aujourd'hui c'est une vague rouge
le président actuel le républicain
donald trump qui affirme aller qui crie
déjà victoire
est-ce que voilà il ne va pas un petit
peu trop vite on sait que jusqu'à
maintenant 1
le dépouillement est toujours en cours
on est très confiant et il faut regarder
ce qui se passe dans les états pivots
notamment dans lés caroline du nord ils
ont arrêté net les gouverneurs
démocrates ont ces états pivots les
comptages des bulletins de vote
et là il ya un an old à des élections
sa menace l'intégrité des élections et
c'est là pourquoi notre président
entrant parle des fraudes
ils essayent de voler cette élection ils
essayent de retarder d'une manière
quelconque départ des manoeuvres
dilatoires
les résultats des élections et on va
faire face à cette situation on n'a pas
de choix et et il a bien souligné les
choses et les camps démocrates
les sondeurs les médias tout le monde
avait dit qu on allait gagner
depuis le début je les dis je dis qu'un
les gagner et qu'il faut attendre les
victoires les différences entre les les
comptes des ben hayden est trempé très
important dans cet art centre toi
jusqu'à cette façon dans les états
petits veaux c'est un nombre très
important même temps l'état dépensé
venez on parle de 700 mille voix
d'avancé par messieurs trempe donc voilà
on en train d'essayer d'éteindre une
image qui n'existe pas et aujourd'hui il
faut juste attendre la fin de cette
polémique qui a été mis en avant par les
démocrates
alors justement les premiers résultats
donnent quand même au vu de la carte que
que l'on a
ce sont des estimations bien évidemment
236 grands électeurs boudent rogers
dubai donne 213 pour donald trump on
attend encore les résultats de la
pennsylvanie de notre homme qui affirme
avoir quand même une avance dans cet
état pour revenir justement à la fraude
qui a été évoqué par le président
américain avant même d'ailleurs le
scrutin il avait laissé entendre qu'il
allait le contester notamment devant la
cour suprême s'il ne sortait pas un
vainqueur mais il se dit tout de même
vainqueur on a l'impression qu'il ya
quand même une contradiction dont la
parole dans les mots du chef de l'état
américain
pas du tout messieurs ne tremble pas est
un jusqu'au boutiste et il va aller
jusqu'au bout et qui va défendre son
gagne pain pour lui il estimé il a
raison il défendre les résultats pour
lui il a gagné les élections on a dans
quatre états qui vaut on a bloqué les
comptage des voix et on le voit là c'est
un manoeuvre dilatoire ou dans l'état de
pennsylvanie
il y avait des modifications qui ont été
effectués par l'état et les
gouvernements et la législature
démocrates à des puits et puis plusieurs
mois promettent pour changer la loi pour
prolonger les comptages pour faire
admettre certains bulletins de vote sont
certains contrôles et des protections
il faut savoir que la cour suprême de
l'état de pennsylvanie est politisé sa
leon à l'élection on ne sait pas nommé
et c'est pas indépendant quand la cour
suprême américaine l'état les magistrats
de la cour suprême de percer sont élus
par les peuples des peines est venu donc
de tous les systèmes et politisé et
c'est pourquoi on dit qu'il ira jusqu'au
bout devant la cour suprême pour voir
une décision non partisan on peut pas
l'avoir devant l'état dépense béni
quelle est votre réaction par rapport à
l'arizona qui aujourd'hui bascule et
pourtant c'est un état clé qui était
important aussi pour les républicains
nous avons des retours qui se passe si
tranchée peut-être y aura des
contestations
aujourd'hui je peux pas vous dire plus
que ça mais il ya aussi des gens tant au
sein de notre parti qui aura
éventuellement des des contestations de
par rapport à l'état de l'arizona
en tout cas c'est cissé les résultats
c'est celle-là résultats il y avait six
et l'état des à la raison alors ils ont
décidé d'élire messieurs byden c'est la
résultats ont essayé un lieu et matière
des contestations parce qu'il ya des
problèmes ou des irrégularités dans les
cas de l'élection il y aura contestation
certainement pourquoi contrairement à
son adversaire donald trump n'est pas
voilà n'a pas plutôt appelé à la
patience et être vraiment voilà sûr à
100% pratiquement d'avoir remporté cette
élection on a vu que dans le camp
buydens contraire ont essayé de rassurer
la population de temporiser et surtout
de patienter puisque on sait que voilà
ça peut durer plusieurs heures plusieurs
jours pour connaître le résultat final
moi je veux bien quand on dit ça mais
c'est parmi neuf qui est monsieur by
vince et présenter devant le peuple
américain pour retarder et pourrait
céder créer un polémique face au peuple
américain pourquoi pourquoi dire cela
alors que ils ont les gouverneurs qui
bloque les comptage des voix et bloquent
depuis des heures par exemple carrés du
nord les georgie ils ont arrêté des
comptes et les voir est ce que vous
estimez c'est normal qu'on tient en
otage une élection nationale des états
unis à des fins politiques comme les
comptes des membres actifs et les et les
gouverneurs instrumentalise les
élections pour retarder retarder et
pauvres et pour remettre en cause
l'intégrité de nos élections pendant de
nombreuses semaines les sondages donnent
et joe biden voilà vainqueur de cette
élection présidentielle dans la dernière
ligne droite on voit bien que donald
trump a rattrapé son retard il a
multiplié les meetings
qu'est ce qui a permis justement
présidents américains de combler ce
retard le contact avec la population
oui il envoie le même message aux
américains depuis ses 4 ans publics font
confiance et tout le monde se trompe en
pensant le contraire
il n'y a pas un message uniforme est
bien palpable de la part des démocrates
mais se trompe pas que convaincre même
les minorités les afro américains les
latinos ils sont venus en nombre
soutenir trompe atteint des niveaux
historiques
c'est pourquoi on en train de gagner
c'est grâce à eux grâce à leur confiance
et que la représentativité de l'ensemble
des mairies kva est aussi un symbole de
cette élection
et c'est grâce à eux et je les remercie
pour leur soutien
randy l'iowa yalouz merci beaucoup
d'avoir répondu à notre question je
rappelle que vous êtes président de
république a offert six france on va
tout de suite
voilà essayer de prendre un petit peu la
tension du côté des démocrates nous
sommes avec théo lobry théo lobry je
rappelle que vous êtes animateur du
comité bernie sanders
en france on a entendu bien évidemment
la confiance et l'optimisme du camp
républicain à l'image du président
américain qui crie d'ores et déjà
victoire
on espérait une vague bleue c'est une
vague rouge mais pour l'instant rien
n'est encore définitif
est-ce que voilà vous vous êtes rassurés
vous attendait justement les les
résultats de ces élections ou au
contraire on commence un petit peu à
s'inquiéter du côté des démocrates
je crois qu'on ne peut pas on peut pas
être assurée dans la configuration
actuelle c'est pas possible d'être trop
d'incertitudes
et puis on a un président qui bien
entendu mais ça c'était prévu mais de
l'huile sur le feu effectivement la
vague que la vague bleue n'est pas là
donald trump avait une fenêtre de tir et
il est en train de la saisirai ce que ça
ira jusqu'au bout sa seule le
dépouillement pourra le dire je crois
que jusqu'à présent ce qui ce qui vaut
mieux faire c'est se terrent regarder
attendre et éviter de éviter de trop en
dire comme le président actuellement joe
biden qui est qui et qui a préféré
rester au delà were plutôt que d'être
sur le terrain on sait que barack obama
l'ancien président des états unis voilà
qui était sur le terrain kamala harris
aussi qui est allé au contact
voilà des américains les démocrates
comptaient beaucoup sur des états clés
comme le texas la floride aussi pour
valeurs inversées un petit peu la
tendance
finalement c'est swing states serait
plus du côté républicain qu'est ce qui a
manqué justement aux démocrates pour
qu'il y ait un résultat vraiment
tranchant dans dans ces états là alors
il tout d'abord deux étaient hier en
pennsylvanie est entré dans le delaware
simplement pour cette soirée électorale
ensuite concernant les swing states bon
le texas est pas vraiment un swing
states mais c'est vrai que par une
petite surprise
il pouvait il pouvait arriver que joe
biden arrive en tête mais pour moi ce
soit la floride où le texas était plutôt
acquise à donald trump donc ça c'est pas
ce qui me surprend le plus ce qui me
surprend le plus c'est plutôt la
fébrilité dans les états de la rose bent
comme au michigan ou encore we stand si
nous embête silvani alors les chiffres
qui sont actuellement diffusées sont à
prendre avec avec des pincettes puisque
on sait qu'il vote par courrier que le
courrier arrive parfois tardivement et
que donald trump a favorisé cette
arrivée tardive du courrier puisque
c'est lui qui a mis en difficulté la
poste américaine
du coup du coup aujourd'hui on se
retrouve dans une situation paradoxale
où donald trump dénoncent l'arrivée
tardive de courrier et de vote alors
même que c'est lui qui a entre autres
participé à ces arrivées tardives
justement comment vous réagissez aussi
également donald trump qui affirme qu'il
est prêt justement à contester ce
scrutin à se présenter devant la
cour suprême moi ça me surprend pas il a
indiqué depuis le début de la campagne
face à joe biden c'est pas très
surprenant finalement il a une cour
suprême qui lui est acquise donc ils
espèrent potentiellement pouvoir aller
devant la cour suprême
si jamais ça se passe mal avec les votes
par correspondance et si jamais ils sont
plutôt favorables à joe biden aller
devant la cour suprême en espérant que
la cour suprême à majorité conservatrice
tranche pour lui ses bras qui s'est pas
acquis puisque comme on dit le vote par
correspondance a été très très important
aux états unis d'ailleurs il y a cette
élection risque de battre des records
au vu du nombre de participations plus
de 100 millions personnes ont voté soit
de manière anticipée ou pouvoir par
correspondance donc il faut attendre
pour connaître les résultats définitifs
vous supportiez bernie sanders ans dans
cette campagne électorale aux états unis
bernie sanders qui a laissé sa place à
joe biden qui est donc aujourd'hui le
concurrent donald trump est ce que vous
pensez que les choses auraient pu être
autrement si bernie sanders avait été là
est ce que la vague bleue aurait été
plus importante
sincèrement je difficile de donner une
réponse aujourd'hui
déjà parce que là le scrutin n'est pas
terminée à entendre l'invité précédent
on croirait que le scrutin est fini et
qu'on a déjà réélu donald trump ce qui
est totalement faux
en plus de ça concernant bernie sanders
c'est difficile à dire que donald trump
a utilisé la ficelle de joe biden le
communiste joe biden le socialiste ça
aurait pu être la même chose avec bernie
sanders qui est même certain d'ailleurs
bernie sanders aurait peut-être mieux
performer dans certains états je pense à
loyaux et encore c'est compliqué
aujourd'hui de dire ce qui aurait pu
être fait avec bernie sanders
tout ce que je vois actuellement c'est
que il y à un camp républicain qui est
acquis absolument à côté de la plaque
c'est à se demander sincèrement si le
cil aiment leur pays puisque ils sont en
train de fracturer le pays
surtout si il prolonge le débat à la
cour suprême
si donald trump eux continuent de dire
que les démocrates vont voler l'élection
ce qui est d'ailleurs paradoxal quand on
voit que actuellement il est plutôt en
position qui est assez favorable de dire
que les démocrates ball l'élection alors
que
peut-être même pas lui imaginé en être
là en être là tout de suite donc donc
voilà c'est un petit peu triste de voir
le camp républicain se comporter comme
ça mais ça surprendra personne
le camp républicain qui crie déjà
victoire mais dans les chiffres et bien
on voit que joe biden est en tête avec
238 grands électeurs et vient de
remporter l'état jumelles et donald
trump 213 électeurs voilà le
dépouillement des votes qui qui continue
en tout cas aux états unis merci
beaucoup
they all aubry d'avoir été avec nous ce
matin en direct sur rt franc je rappelle
que vous êtes animateur du comité à
bernie sanders